let's talk about what
frustrates you most about being an
independent filmmaker i know we want to
keep it positive and it's all great you
know follow your bliss and everything
but let's talk about just the reality of
what sometimes frustrates you you're
willing to work through it i understand
that but
the most frustrating the enemy of every
independent filmmaker i know is time not
money time time there's not enough time
to do everything and and um and now
especially when filmmakers are
responsible for
researching film festivals and managing
distribution managing marketing and
doing all these things and you have a
life and you maybe have kids and you
maybe have to make money doing a day job
and just having time to do everything is
really the struggle um and that's where
it's frustrating because my my my eyes
are definitely bigger than my stomach
you know and what really frustrates me
actually is
not just having enough taking so long to
get things done but
because things take so much time they
have to mean more i mean obviously i'm
not a big filmmaker at all um but i'm in
a place where because it takes so long
to make a film i can't really it's hard
for me to find time to experiment i
would love to
experiment with the form more i'd love
to try doing a film that's all based on
improv for example i did a little improv
in favor and i was
absolutely amazed at how far i was able
to get
actors
this is one little part we improved
i gave them situation
and they knew the characters and not
much else now i was just blown away
about what they were able to do with it
this is and i'm like i can almost make
an entire film like this come up with a
with a structure
the way this is the way like larry david
works come with a structure scene by
scene
work with the actors get to know the
characters and then throw them in
situations and shoot with two cameras
and let them improv the scene two or
three times and almost you know cut it
together like a doc you know let it be
jagged and find them and i think wow it
could be really interesting to go to
places you wouldn't know and performance
stuff you could never really get to with
something that's scripted because it's
so
unhinged potentially
i don't know that i would have time
to do that just because it takes long to
make a film i've got so many scripts i
want to do
and only so much so much life left to
live to do them right where i'm viable
but the take to do an affiliate
experiment let's take a year take two
years i don't really have that time and
that's really what's frustrating is you
are kind of handcuffed that's the thing
you're the most limited on money as
limiting as it is
is there's less of a limitation than
just hours in the day days in the week
weeks in the month yeah i agree
you